it is a climax and a turning point the
investigations gone on for some period
of time and now you know to invoke the
old cliche it's sort of time to fish or
cut bait and see exactly what the
conclusions are you do not file a
document that looks like this if your if
your investigations so you know is in
the final stages a lot of analysis about
the Michael Flint sentencing document
the was filed by the special counsel
among it among the pages the defendant
also provides useful information
concerning blacked out in the document
you we do see quote given the defendants
substantial assistance and other
considerations a sentence at the low end
of the guideline range including a
sentence that does not impose a term of
incarceration is appropriate and
warranted what does this tell us what
doesn't it tell us and where are we back
with our panel Tom Rogan commentary
writer for the Washington Examiner Molly
Hemingway senior editor at the
Federalist and Charles Lyon opinion
writer for The Washington Post Molly you
know for all the folks who say this is
all coming to a head it could be over
soon looking at this document we can't
read a lot because we don't see it all
but it doesn't seem like that it's
impossible to know and it's frustrating
the lack of information that we get in
this document but I think it's worth
remembering that that the reason why we
know about this phone call that he had
with the Russian ambassador is because a
member of the Obama administration
leaked that information to the media
that was a criminal leak it damaged
national security and no one has been
held accountable for it it is it is
important to remember that the Obama
administration rather viciously set this
Russian narrative through leaks that was
one of them
there was also the very quickly k-- of
the information that James Comey had
briefed Donald Trump on a particularly
ridiculous aspect of the discredited
dossier and there were also the leaks
about Jeff Sessions completely innocuous
meetings with ambassador his lyac as
well that really set the narrative it
undermined the administration it was how
so many members of the administration
were hand hounded and it set up
justification for a sprawling Special
Counsel it is important to remember how
we got here it seems also that the
Special Counsel despite these redactions
is putting out through court filings
more of the picture we are going to get
another one eventually about Paul
Manafort as well Chuck I speaking of
pictures they could hang this in the
National Gallery it looks like modern
art from the 1960s you know those black
lines across
yeah I'm not actually sure how much more
we're gonna find out about anything
underlying this he does have in the
man-of-war thing he's got some quarrel
going on with Manta fort now as to
whether mana Ford lied they're even
talking about retrying him on eight of
ten counts you know this room this this
latest revelation has the same structure
as a lot of them in the past the Special
Counsel does something it's not entirely
clear what it means people start
declaring what they think it means based
on very insufficient information and
then it all goes quiet again for a while
I think the big change now this
information is arriving at a time of the
Democrats are gonna take over the house
and what's really gonna be significant I
think in this story is how they pick up
the committee investigations that are
derived off of this story Tom yeah I
mean we know that we don't know is the
ultimate thing as with this it reminds
me of Angleton the CIA cata spy so you
know it's the wilderness of mirrors but
ultimately I think one of the
interesting things here we do know that
Mike Flynn had the pre-existing
relationship with the Turkish government
that was listed in this filing we know
that President Erdogan has been very
very interested in trying to get his
holds on kerlick a cleric Gulen we don't
know exactly the details of that but
this there are areas here speaking to
foreign policy reaching beyond rush
beyond Russia that could come up so
we'll see you know it's just interesting
to see the Logan Act mentioned you know
we'll be reaching out to foreign
governments here was a incoming national
security adviser it's not like he was
out of government dealing with foreign
governments that's why it's important to
remember how we got here that was a
leaked and ally concluded that they were
looking into the Logan Act they also
leave that they were worried about
blackmail something that doesn't appear
to our knowledge in this sentencing
agreement there there is there is a lot
that has not been helped there are a lot
of people who haven't been held
accountable for their role in setting up
this narrative which is turning out to
not have you know we've gotten to the
sentencing now and we don't have
evidence of Mike Flynn being a traitor
that's important